[Music]
Runk Sacramento I'll be there January
13th added show we just added another
show in Sacramento because the first one
sold out then it'll be and Brea
California Phoenix Arizona El Paso Texas
Albuquerque New Mexico Colona BC uh and
we just also added another show in
uh Vancouver get your tickets Chris
lea.com the first one sold out
um check out grow or die my new special
my fifth comedy special Chris lea.com
I'm very proud of it would appreciate it
if you go and uh check it out go get it
at chris.com and uh other than that dude
let's get into the episode this is
[Music]
congratulations
congratulations my gosh man it was one
of those days where let me tell you
something man one of those days
where I woke
up uh I don't even understand what the
what happened honestly the day I don't
really get how it got away from me it
just kind of like I woke up at when did
I wake up like this is the thing I don't
even understand we have kids all right
the kids woke
up I genuinely have no memory of waking
up this morning that's how out of it I
was um I must have got up with the
kids Kristen must have got up too no I
got up with Billy oh that's what
happened I remember yay I got up got
Billy out of the crib put him in a
little jumper you know one of those
things where he's jumping he's going
crazy with these things now you know
just like he's
like jumping up and down fell asleep on
the couch Billy didn't make a peep you
know he was just playing in the jumper
Calvin was up playing with
stuff and then all of a sudden it was
1:30 I guess I fell asleep on the couch
for so long because Kristen was up
and dude I don't know what happened man
and then I just went back into bed a
little look I did shows this weekend in
oxar California and they were really fun
I did a lot of new stuff I even did new
stuff on the new stuff like I have a new
hour that I'm doing and I didn't do some
of it because I wanted to do other new
stuff anyway I
now I'm 43 I'm exhausted after I do my
my shows the next the Sunday I'm
exhausted dude I woke up then at
6 I and it's and now it's 8 and I'm like
I went to go I took Calvin to go get hot
chocolate yeah I got uh uh regular
coffee and I I was I'm like so out of it
dude and I'm and I guess I'm like okay
well the day is over so just go to bed
after this so I I lost today or or did I
win are those days awesome or you
because I don't feel you know I go to
the the the John Lenin quote where it's
like every day where you don't I don't
know the quote really but it's something
about how if you're have if you're if
you're having a good time then it's not
time wasted and and I guess I was having
a bonker's good time sleeping and you
know so I but I also feel guilty but
then it's like okay I did the shows what
should I I feel like
that I I I I don't know
man um I do want to talk about this
um the uh the sh the movie the the leave
the world alone what is it called the
world the one that you're typing right
now Leave the World Behind everyone's
roasting Julie Roberts about her dancing
in it
dude I I I don't here's the deal okay I
was watching Le Leave the World Behind
first of all I don't like the movie okay
I said
it the acting is phenomenal I said it
don't like the movie and I'm not even a
guy who doesn't like a movie because of
how the ending is but dude saw the movie
the ending was it just I didn't like the
movie everyone's talking about this
movie it's number one on Netflix number
two on Netflix Julie Julia
Roberts there she is so awesome at
acting she is the crem de La Creme of
actors okay there is a movie there's a
scene where she dances with a guy
marshala Mahala what is it Mah Maha Ali
I mean that's you know there's an extra
Allah in there that I don't you know
Mah
Mah and dude she's dancing and she is so
weirdly dancing and everyone's roasting
her online for it you put the video
here but let me tell you something about
this I didn't know that people were
roasting her and I saw the movie right
when it came out so they probably
weren't roasting her yet so I saw this
movie okay we can't so first of all
she's dancing to that [__] baby
you're not drying you get so excited oh
how I like it I try but I can't find it
oh you're dancing real slow but I get
real you're making it hard for me wow I
guess I know that whole song I had no
idea wow
baby wait go you excited ohing real slow
get real making it hard for
me like we sex then oh
yeah oh yeah whatever anyway um that
song by next is it why do I know it I I
why do I know this
dude I don't know but that song gave me
eargasms when I was younger I never
liked that song honestly but anyway it's
dope that they put that in this movie in
the in an end of the world movie you
know what I'm saying like they like the
producer the director was like yo I know
the perfect
song oh we're dancing real slow and
you're making it hard for me that means
penis by the way um he does not talking
about difficult I mean he is talking
about difficult but it's an inuendo and
he's talking about hard he's talking
about his penis
you you know is that the one that feels
a little poke coming through on
you so fraking to the point so
um uh anyway I'm watching this movie and
I and now Julia Roberts is dancing now
look if you think of a Great White
actress dancing you probably think bad
you know just like has so much money
what is her life like she doesn't dance
you know like you know how like
Gangsters Don't Dance they Boogie how M
10 said that and then it's like well
dude nobody doesn't dance more than a
gangster okay but then it's like a
really really really really rich white
woman and I don't mean a housewife when
the when the when the husband leaves and
she's got the kitchen to herself in her
two-bedroom house I'm talking about
someone with houses that has people do
[__] for them day and night they don't
dance dude they they get people to dance
for them they're kings and queens
they're just you know they'll put on
necks and they'll be like I feel like
dancing I need someone to fulfill that
dance for
me and then someone comes out oh they're
dancing real slow you're making it hard
for me and they don't move [__] so Julia
Roberts is an actress though and this
scene calls upon her to dance so we get
to see either how this character Julia
Roberts is playing is dancing and how
she decides his character is dancing or
how the real Julia Robert dances we
don't know we don't know so roasting her
is pretty much silly because it's the
character
okay and there's this thing on Tik Tok
where it's like and the acting award
goes to Maha La laa for keeping a
straight face while watching Julie
Roberts trying to dance now we don't
like that kind of roasting Hero on
congratulations because this is the
character dude if I'm in a movie and it
for me to dance unless I play a
dancer I'm doing it silly okay why
because it adds to the movie you see me
dancing on TV I'm having a a silly
time now if I'm in Magic mic and I gotta
do
p
p and I gotta be real sexy I got to take
dance classes okay
I got to actually try but this here
she's dancing a a little poke coming
through on you so she's doing it like
the character either way I was watching
this movie and I was in by the way the
first half of this movie and the dancing
happens in the first half of the
movie or like maybe into the it's into
the movie now Mah
La Mah la la la la la la of course is
good at dancing he's better at dancing
than he is at smiling when Mahala La D
Smiles he knows that that gets the
penties wet and I just go it gets the
penties wet it kind of It kind of even
gets my panties wet and I'm not not in a
gay way I'm just like I'll give it to
him I'll piss a little
bit uh you know what I'll let it out a
little bit you know when a guy's really
good-looking as a man if you're really
comfortable with your heterosexuality
you you got to get wet too and piss a
little bit just give it to him you know
what I'm talking
about
right
so Julia Roberts starts dancing and dude
I'm first of all I'm in the I'm in it
I'm in the movie okay fine that's cool
Julia Roberts starts dancing and she
dances very
weird actually no even worse than that
she dances kind of weird
and it's very subtle and kind of
weird and I'm going to just go ahead and
say she did it as a character cuz she is
just top notot jaing but when I saw her
dancing in that here I'll play it a
little bit I'm not going to do the music
because we'll get demonetized
but God she's a great actress dude I
mean she's dancing like she's you know
in like Westside Story the blind
version but she's just got no and and
and next to a black guy who's Obviously
good at dancing because he's black but
man he
she is just like God she's so good dude
when I saw this scene I was like Julia
Roberts I actually texted the group chat
when I saw this dancing I texted my my
friends I go man Julia Roberts is on
another level of acting and she really
is dude I love Julie Roberts and I
always
have and she is doing it like a lane
from Seinfeld's a little bit but you
know it's okay but that movie boy I I
didn't I'm not wasn't in it you know but
she was also like playing you know a
kind of like a Karen role so that's how
they dance uh she killed it dude hats
off to Julie Roberts I think she should
win an Oscar just for that dancing best
dance with mash La La Al
II
um yeah there's something I don't get
about Marshal laa Ali I guess they're
doing um Blade the movie with him and
because everything is so woke his part
is getting smaller and smaller and
they're just getting more and more like
transgender and women people in it
that's what I heard that's word on the
streets dude but I'm just vibing you
know what I mean word on the street is
I'm you know I'm just saying I'm trying
to become a conspiracy theorist because
I just think that those kind of at least
I would have [__] to
do all the time you know what I'm saying
like if you're con you're if you're a
conspiracy theorist think about how
never how you're never bored ever ever
ever ever bored you just go like this
you start to get bored you you know like
you you you get home and you're like oh
my next thing isn't until 4:30 and then
you go but the government's corrupt and
why well there was no plane that hit the
Pentagon I mean show me the proof and
then you just start going into a rabbit
hole you don't even need the internet
you could just do it in your own head if
you've seen loose change if youve seen
Ze guys you're good you know what I'm
saying like that's the kind of stuff
that I'm trying to get to and I can't
dude I can't I'm just too logical now I
don't mean that the government isn't
lying to us like my mom said to me today
she was
like you know cuz Calvin had a fever uh
2 3 days ago but it was for like 8 hours
it was like one of those kids fevers
where they get a fever but then they're
like psych um and he fell asleep and he
was having fever
dreams and uh I heard him crying and I
ran up and he was having a hard time he
was like standing up in bed I didn't
know if he was awake or not and he kept
going like this he kept going and I'm
like buddy are you sleeping or not he
kept going uh and I was like oh my gosh
buddy are you okay and then he was
trying to explain to me what happened
anyway
the dream was later on he explained it
to me when he woke up he was like I had
a dream that I was eating paint and
became paint and I was like oh wow
that's actually terrifying for a three
and a half-year-old
but so we were supposed to have family
dinner today I obviously slept through
today but my mom and dad were texting
hey you guys coming over because we have
family time Sundays and we were like you
know calin's been sick really sick
really the [__] just kind of lay in
bed and uh and my mom said oh if cevin
was sick did you guys get your flu shots
and I just texted back the government
lies to us you know nice mothers son
kind of
texting and my my mom writes let me look
look here uh did you get your flu
shots he's okay I said mom says true did
you get the flu shot did you all get a
guys did you guys get a flu shot I said
no the government lies to us so it so it
should be
okay and my mom writes yeah it does but
it's good not to get the flu and then my
brother writes the government in quotes
anyway
dude I want to
be I want to be that guy you know and
I'm not saying because so my point is
dude I know the government lies to us
dude I live that lifestyle so don't come
to me and like oh Chris is acting like
it on the podcast and he's not really
bad about it but dude he is he is he
walks with the metal when he's [__]
texting like he's real he's
real you know what I'm saying don't act
like I don't walk with the metal I walk
with the metal
H so it's
like tread lightly when you're talking
to me about conspiracy theorist stuff
all right and that's okay but I know
about this stuff and I don't believe in
all of that I believe in very very few
conspiracy theories but I'm working on
it I'm trying to get there I would love
to believe Joe Biden is a lizard or
Donald Trump is a hologram are you
kidding me
dude I would
love
it I'd never get bored
I you can make up conspiracy theories
you can make them up if you don't even
if they're not enough make more up and
have more people follow them [__] qanon
zanon I want to have a new Anon anyway
um LBGTQ Anon right have that well
that'd be a great title if they didn't
that would for sure flag it I said flag
it by the way
um how about how about tekashi 69
actually his name is truly tekashi
6699 really is what his name
is that's interesting cuz
66 is already on the way to six and
99 is already on the way you can use the
last part of nine to Trail into the next
nine anyway I'm a
linguist
um bro I don't here's the thing all
right I don't know how much money
tekashi 69 has I I don't I I don't I
know how much money comedians make I I
you know I'm assuming Brands probably
don't [__] with tekashi 69 because of
how
he's uh
poison but I guess two years
ago
um he
was sued because he was swinging a
bottle around cuz somebody called him a
rat which by the way you
are you know what I'm
saying like how could you be mad it's
like Chris your shoulders go on for days
uh I'm not mad I know right Chris you're
size 13 can't imagine what you got in
the downstairs area what am I going to
do get mad at that now I get it dude
it's
facts you know Chris your hairline only
went back a little bit and it'll
probably stay there for the rest of your
life you're all good so don't worry
about it dude I'm not going to get I'm
not going to I know that you
know hey Chris it's a little it's a
little tough for you to lose the the the
you know the body fat in in behind your
back above your ass you know technically
love handles dude I'm not going to go
swinging a bottle around right yeah but
I I start thinking about focus on my
chest then okay well I got my chest
peeking out though right maybe I work my
chest harder the skin will gravitate
towards my chest it'll pull the skin
back from the you know what I mean I
don't know and that's a conspiracy
theory that I'm thinking of that that
that I could actually spend time on but
anyway let's go back to that tekashi
thing what you're a rat all
good you do what rats do right probably
got a little cheese in your
pocket you
go tell on people so you get a reduced
you know he didn't go to jail Sarat all
good
so now you're at a strip club which is
by the way derel City you're not going
to be you're not going to meet Savory
individuals there right I'm not saying
there's not Savory individuals there but
there are also non- Savory individuals
there right you ever been to the strip
club in the daytime I have you know
who's there alone guys you know who what
they are probably not Savory you know
how I know I went alone
once
okay I wasn't in the Savory business
back then right
so so he's in the strip club somebody
calls him a rat and he starts swinging a
bottle by the
way don't swing the bottle because you
go like this well that's what I you know
what I mean it's like cake doesn't get
mad it's cake swings a bottle hits a
stripper big big mistake all right now
she W 9.8 $25 million on by the way this
is crazy that she won that
much you know you should never be able
to sue someone more money than they
would have taken for sure if the thing
happened beforehand you know what like
like like if beforehand you're asked hey
would you take a bottle to the nogget
for $9.8 million and if somebody would
go are you [__] kidding me yes that's
too
much you know what I'm saying you she
should have got like a million cuz then
or I don't know she probably would have
taken [__] what 20 grand to take a
bottle to the Noggin but nine 10 million
That's crazy dude you know because then
you get hit and then you got to be like
wait got to take care of my medical
bills but then also the trauma and it's
like all right dude you know it sucks he
hit you in the Noggin but how much would
you get you know what I mean what would
I get for somebody to smash me in a in
in in the head with a bottle of cryistal
well if you know if it changed her life
if she can't walk right or something or
she's
Dumber
uh not that she's a [__] you know
doctor she's a dancer but um you know
then yeah then you know what she does
deserve 10 million so [__] it actually
but whatever we don't know the ins and
outs of it she got her money he didn't
pay for two years and now they're like
the judge is like now they can the the
people whoever the power thatb can come
in take what they need to and sell it
off to give to to get the money so this
guy's going to be out $10
million um
damn the they can break locks necessary
to gain access to any real property wow
that's crazy
dude that's look at the oh look at the
gash actually that's rough man this God
bless God bless look at
this uh her attorney told us he tried
hitting someone else for calling him a
rat but he missed and clocked Alexis
instead is that her real name or a
stripper
name
um so here it says the injuries resulted
in a trip to the ER and she got several
Staples to close the
wound well then that's it I mean that's
bad oh there's actually footage of the
fight well let's get involved let's get
into it it's a different thing it's not
it
oh oh she was arrested his girlfriend on
a felony charge assaulting himh oh man
this this is that's these people are
good
people what's she hitting him with what
is that a [__] wacky
I that that's not a 2x4
dude bro this is
crazy oh I like how he stepped in into
it look at dude his cars you know his
green ass car with the pink wow she got
arrested
wild
um anyway they recalled 2 million uh
Teslas
so what is it like to be Elon Musk
dude I they
I mean to H for how many Teslas are
there by the way in the in the world and
this guy had to recall two M oh I would
I tell you what if I was a a a car guy
not a car guy an owner of a car I know
he does more than that but dude say I'm
say you're the head of uh Mitsubishi or
uh Mercedes whatever the hell right
Alpha Romeo you go they go hey they I'm
Mr Romeo okay that's me hello hello
president Romeo yeah that's me president
of Alfa Romeo hey so we have to recall 2
million um of cars oh yeah ah I give
up dude I I I I I'm done I lost like I
that's it I take it I take the money I
got from being Mr Romeo and then I go
from being the Alpha Romeo and then I
[__] leave dude I'm done do you know
what I'm saying I don't know how you you
it it was like the guy from the Alaska
Airlines was it Alaska Airlines where
the plane crashed and he resigned he's
like I'm the president of Alaska
Airlines I I I I I okay it crashed I'm
done I failed I'm gone dude I leave
that's
it that's it if I'm doing standup and
all of a sudden you know people are just
zero laughing and then start shooting
each other oh I I'm oh that's it that
was my last show that's it yo hey every
that was my last show thank thanks
everyone sorry you didn't enjoy it and
sorry you started murdering each other
but I you know go see Tom sagui he's
here next
month I I don't understand Elon Musk I'm
dude you recall two million Teslas I'm
done bro also the kill switch and the
car that they're going to implement in
2026 yo they're going to f oh
man you know you know they're just going
to they're going to abuse that hey dude
I'm a consp iracy theorist that's one I
I got it I I'm never bored never
bored uh are you kidding me there's
Doritos
liquor why is everybody getting into the
hard liquor
game what the
[__] hey
Doritos you're
disgusting
Doritos you're [__] absolutely
disgusting dude I've the last time I ate
Doritos was oh my God decades ago hey
Doritos to release nacho cheese flavored
alcoholic drink that tastes like crisps
hey
disgusting hey you lose
resign oh my God it's called
empirical that's the company they're
using okay look at it's got a it's got a
in the ad it's got a a drink on the
rocks with a Dorito chip over it like a
to Lime like on the thing just
disgusting
dude Doritos are you ever eat a Dorito
and you're just like do you ever eat a
Dorito and not think oh this is killing
me right now I don't I don't eat Doritos
but and that's not to say I don't I did
eat a brownie last night and ice cream
and
fries and that's why my love handles
aren't going away
but no I ate those a few nights ago
sweetie you're not part of this when I
have you on as a guest be a guest but
don't be chiming in saying I ate six
Reese's peanut butter cups when that was
three nights before this not last night
she says and the Reese's she made them
dude so she made Reese's Peanut Butter
Cups which is they were really good she
dude she put dark chocolate on him which
I was like ah nah but then I ate another
one and I was like yeah actually okay
dude milk chocolate [__] dark chocolate
in the
[__] milk when someone looks at me
and they say I like dark chocolate
better I go okay communist milk
chocolate is the
[__] that's it it was it was milk
chocolate tasted like dark chocolate
that's why it was good the second
time anyway dude Doritos liquor why is
everybody got to having a liquor thing
why does why like I'm just going to
throw names out there I guarantee they
have liquor companies Mario Lopez
there's [__] no way in hell that he
doesn't have a liquor company or you
know what I mean there's [__] no way
in hell
I bet Gary Oldman I bet he has a [__]
liquor and it's sold in like France and
and and you
know Mary Mary Lopez and Oscar De La
Hoya have a tequila together there you
go there you go I I knew I knew without
knowing because obviously they do why
does how much [__] drinking needs to
happen I don't even mean drinking
alcohol how many things do people need
to
drink I'm [__] satiated dude I drink
water and coffee that's all I drink
I love how Mario Lopez came out with
Trump and they were trying to drag him
Mario Lopez came out with Trump on the
UFC with Trump and uh uh what do you
call it um uh uh Dana White and it's
like oh people trying to drag Mary Lopez
[__] that I love Mar Lopez dude how
about this
man of course Mary Lopez voted for Trump
he's Mario
Lopez if you got money you voting for
Trump
if you got money you're voting for Trump
period unless you know you feel really
guilty for some reason right like a lot
of white women are like well we still
got to do the right thing that's what
they think the right thing
is I just want Darth Vader to be
president
um how about the movie um that came
out Maestro
Maestro with um Bradley uh Wills Bradley
uh Cooper and he has a b big Jewish nose
on it and
that's
um bro look at
this Bradley Cooper caught some Flack
for revealing that he doesn't allow
chairs on his movie sets but it turns
out he ain't alone whether it's rules
for sitting or other bands you might
have heard about
this did an interview with somebody did
an interview with Spike Lee uh not a big
chair
guy
um who
else oh dude okay so this is um come to
find out he's far from the only
filmmaker who enforces stringent
guidelines on set and even for the chair
issue he's in good company with
Christopher noan and Zach Sneider that's
not true I worked with Zack Sneider he
had chairs I sat
down wrong there you go
whistleblower hell yeah I'm a
whistleblower dude I'm a chair
whistleblower I'm a director's I'm a
chair on set whistleblower that's
awesome um look at
this an hathway and RDJ rep claim Chris
Nolan doesn't do chairs and Snider
himself says there are no chairs allowed
in the sets hey whistleblower yes he
does I sat on his set a lot I was in the
movie until I got cut out and dude I sat
a lot actually a lot of downtime and it
was [__] 1550 degrees in Albuquerque
I'll be in Albuquerque soon come see me
chris.com
um yeah by the way whistleblower I love
you know that's just snitch ass [__]
why do people call it whistleblower like
it's some some Noble thing dude you
snitched
um what is
this not safe for work content let's
absolutely click it bring the cam
something oh boy let me just tell you
something right now anybody with that
voice where it you know what I mean
where it's like the voice forgot to wake
up for the day that's a dude that is not
to be trifled with you know what I'm
saying nobody with that voice is timid
no
way
nobody with that voice is is [__]
timid come on dude I already accepted
that I'm I it's okay to watch this here
we
go bring the camera bring the camera
like he's so confident [__] bring the
camera bring the camera all the young
girls who want to make life with [__]
your [__] will perish with you in hell
oh my God doing may your [__] perish
with you may your smooth [__] oh likes
it though you know what I mean [__] and
[__] Parish oh my God why is he
describing it like he likes
it [__] Kia [__] and [__]
Parish dude the worst WWF speech promo
that he
cut dude when he goes you're
will perish dude that was awesome this
guy is my favorite WWE uh
guy oh dude somebody yeah where are the
rappers dude let's go let's get this
sampled you're pussyy bring the camera
oh dude I love how he takes I need the
camera the camera bring the camera here
dude this guy's controls so wow he
controls
that's
amazing all right I went potty here we
go um I actually had a thing I wanted to
talk about you know the year's coming to
an end and it's going to be
Christmas I put together five
shows that I thought were
gangster all right I wrote it down where
the hell are they here we go these are
the shows when it comes to watchability
dude
the five shows I liked in 2023 when it
comes to watchability now look you know
me dude I won't sit there and watch like
certain types of shows so if comedy is
out the you know I'm not going to sit
and watch you know I don't know how the
the latest episode of
uh I don't even know what a comedy what
what show what a comedy show is uh
what's the one with the Modern Family I
don't know is that on even still no clue
okay well I don't know what these shows
are like so I take those out of the list
all
right uh I like Thrillers I like
mindbenders I like you know sultry
sexual shows I like shows where got
action
shows I got the five shows that I think
you should watch when it comes to
watchability not
necessarily fantastic art
okay these are the
shows number one The Watcher that show
was good it was Goofy but good
watchability who done it the whole time
didn't understand couldn't figure it out
wanted to know what was happening
couldn't thank you for that show number
two Silo what the these are no
particular order ah that chick is a
great actress and also what they're
going up and down and [__] in that thing
why is a silo out there dude and now
what at the end there's more silos
they're not the only one oh what the
[__] that's a little bit of a spoiler
alert but not really
dude
um but it's like so you know they're all
in this like compound everything is
brown in it there's no color on the
show um and what's going on dude that
you watch that show you're like a what's
going on there you go that's the number
one thing about shows that I need to I
need to watch I if I watch it and I'm
going what's going on here that's that's
it dude
okay another show I loved watching
hijack an action how they going get off
this plane what the [__] how they gonna
how's he gonna do this
right I'm in in a confined space what
the f all right I'll watch
it okay every show can't be Seance I'll
watch it Seance was fantastic but that
was
20122 another show I that was Apple TV
that was ID Ela Ed Elba is the [__] of
course we all know that
Mah La Ali is [__] gunning for Idis
Elba
right the next one that I liked watching
gen V so silly so good with the
superhero Thing a take on superhero
thing absolutely loved watching it
[__] Patrick Schwarzenegger's good
actor who knew the son of Arnold
Schwarzenegger Patrick Schwarzenegger
better actor than Arnold Schwarzenegger
not that reneger deserves an Oscar for
anything but killing it um and it was
funny too gen V that was the offshoot of
the
boys the boys is a good show great show
gen V great
show number five this show called
Obsession k k dude so sexual this show
what was going on so wild lot of sultry
stuff going on good acting bro I'm a I'm
a [__] TV
reviewer these are the five watchable
shows watched them straight through
loved them now now other shows I watched
straight through didn't like them I'll
watch a whole show and not like it the
tutors six seasons zipped right through
it this year didn't necessarily like it
okay watch the whole thing the
consultant with that dude that's the
actor
um such a great actor show is not good
watch the whole thing uh that Apple TV
show with Jennifer Garner
the last thing he told me bad show watch
the whole
thing Monarch watching it on episode
five got bad gonna watch the whole
thing
committing it's fine love that dur got
his Andre home got his [__] that that's
awesome he's good in it there's some
fine stuff in it Show's not for me dude
and I love monsters [__] can't wait to
see Godzilla minus one dude can't wait
to see Godzilla minus
one that's a the movie
though it is Christmas so let's go
through with this this is Jonathan I'm
delivering your order from br's Pizza
Palace I just got caught by a roadblock
or something there's just a bunch of
cars on the road [__] they're shooting
all right this is a light show that this
guy put up for Christmas of like a green
cartoon type thing and he synced it with
this audio right so this is what the
Christmas light display is
saying let me get down underneath my
feet and get my gun you pulled up on the
wrong got an automatic down here
somewhere
you he's got a Grenade is this uh South
Park this can't be a real actual call
but this is is this guy's Christmas
decoration hey see Cee fire Cee fire I
got a delivery that's going to be free
if I'm not there in 13 minutes okay and
if you don't move I'm going to take you
out fine me your wedding he like a will
feral thing I got him okay I'm almost
there I'll see you in a few minutes
pizza's still fresh this is like a Jerky
Boys album thing that's hilarious that
that's the [__] Christmas DEC why
can't Christen decorate stuff like that
dude I mean so annoying for the
neighbors just constantly just have
PTSD what is this
uh
uh is
that what is
that I'm trying to look in the comments
of
what well
whatever um that's probably illegal
right there's no way they can have that
going there's no way they can have that
that going in the neighborhood wow
that's amazing that they did that good
job let's look at some of deserv it
scales these I love these I
love um all right here we
go running through oh
no oh he died right I mean
that's yo how about weird big rooms like
this with nothing in it
and this guy just ran head on into
something he thought was open that is so
obviously not open and this guy's so
drunk though swinging his towel
around this looks like a rehab center oh
my god dude he
died he's out dude that that hurt too
much for it to be a 10 that can't be a
deserved scale 10 that is so bad oh my
God the outfit all gray takes a
that is rough bro that is a six that's
too too much pain for a deserve
it okay let's see this other one girl uh
this is from girls got a Graham she's
trying to crawl up on the
beam let me guess she
falls she deser
well oo
[Music]
ooh that's her L1 is gone dude just
how did she fall that
bad oh you found some violent ones dude
this is just uh that's a four that if
that's your mom you go mom's
dead yeah she did do it to herself yeah
yeah she did do it to herself that is
more of a deserv it than the last one is
what you're saying cuz the guy just made
a mistake this one did it for herself
she definitely did it to herself but
this this probably isn't as hurtful as
the one that the guy did too too unless
it looked like her neck could have
snapped in which case she doesn't
deserve that but the deserves a scale
I'd say this is a six the last one is a
four i i a a all right let's see what
this one
is uh this girl's got a Graham uh one is
good the coffee room my day she
says now
that is a 10 that is such a quick T dude
this coffee R my day coffee went out
with one she threw
dude she threw a coffee out of the
window she was going to litter and the
window was closed and it went all over
her car and that my friends is a 10
deserved scale you were going to litter
you know what if I did that which I
would throw I would probably litter
something like that if I was in the
right mood and if that happened to me I
go like this yeah I you know what charge
it to the game 100% charge to the game
thanks Jesus Christ now I believe in you
because I got what I deserved
immediately that is a 10 a 10 I would go
like that I would go like this you know
what I don't want this coffee I'm going
to throw it out boom I go that's a 10 10
in the deserv it scale I wish it was
filmed it on my podcast that is
great let's see another deserv it scale
here oh this girl's just trying to do
crit
bro she's just trying to do CrossFit man
she's trying to do do better
and and get a good get her you know her
tendon's all strong oh
[__] she was trying to do one of
those pull-ups that were like why do
they do those those jerky ones I don't
know CrossFit is so violent
bro the cameraman oh just couldn't help
himself I hope she's okay
uh ah
I guess I would
say someone said so zero she did zero
those those are that's the pull-ups
she's trying to do what are they called
again I don't know the swinging pull-ups
bro that's a uh that's a F four she you
know what just do regular pull-ups I
would say that's a six cuz just do
regular pull-ups and and you won't smash
your back like that
okay wow
dude let's do one more
oh I can already tell I'm G to love this
one I dude this is the absolute oh you
know what how I've never seen more
of from the first clip from the first
frame here the makings of a 10 deserv it
scale the guy is on a single trampoline
one of those little indoor trampolines
and he's in front of he's on his TV room
right bouncing he's overweight okay
that's high on already the deser it
scale he's got big basketball shorts on
high on the deserved scale to you know
what I mean and then and then a [__]
oversized uh um uh tank top and he's
over 50 and he has a dragon tattoo on
his shoulder so this guy is
absolutely asking for
it so let's see what's
up oh oh oh oh oh
oh and he's acting silly on it he's not
actually doing it this if this isn't a
10 this guy has to die for it to not be
a 10 he deserves so
much oh dude I paused it so funny he's
falling already okay here we
[Laughter]
go that's a 10 that is an absolute 10
the thump and
oh is so
good look at him what a piece of [__]
doing like that like he's too good for
it
oh the Dragon Tattoo
dude the [__] Dragon Tattoo dunce
with a dragon
tattoo oh that's a good
[Laughter]
one
like like what is he doing dude who is
he
[Laughter]
towy that groan is Top Notch
dude oh
[__] this is funny this is so good this
is a 10 I got to send it to all my
friends this is just
fantastic
oh this is fantastic sending it to some
friends right now disrespectful don't
give a [__] sending to some friends
right now disrespectful don't give a
[__] uh there we
go H yeah and he wasn't even that hurt
all good man 100% of 10 on the deserv it
scale love
it
Jesus let's look at some tenders here we
haven't seen some
tenders
okay thanks but I'm not just wait hold
on what is this thanks but I'm not just
got some drama with my step brother that
started Friday and it has me feeling
stuck on what to do and like I want to
talk to my mom about it but I'm nervous
and embarrassed so then other person
says well that's so fun family drama
always sucks if you'd like any advice
from a guy who you just met on a dating
app with no judgments feel free haha no
guarantees what I'll say will be helpful
though so then the person says well it's
a little personal but it's cuz Friday
night I had plans with my step brother
as we were meeting for a modeling
interview and the thing is that during
the interview we had
sex well like it's been bothering me
lately oh my is that it is there is oh
my god dude yeah that that had bother me
lately although it's not blood right
so that can't be real though that the
that can't be real you know what he's
trying to do scam
them there you go figured it out I know
stuff
dude look at this here we go here's
another one uh totally what about you
you can't be just a boring traditor this
chick in her bra is saying on Tinder
part of me likes partying live music
standup comedy another part just wants
to read a book on a rainy day and fall
asleep watching old movies wow I hate
this guy who says [__] like that like
it's
2001 um oh my God this person says says
liking stand-up comedy is a pretty big
big red flag are you aware of
that oh my God this guy says first I
hear that how is that a red
flag she says standup comedy is 90%
racist and sexist jokes oh my
God I
agree I
agree dude that's what a f see dude this
the best thing about Tinder and [__] and
this online stuff you it out before you
even meet up I mean dude remember when
you had to go on dates with people and
you'd find out that like you know one
time I was on a date with it with
someone and she was like yeah I had
really bad postpartum I tried to kill my
son and I was like check please and I
don't even by the way postpartum is real
my mom had that [__] like I'm but like
dude hey if you want the choice for a
killer to be in your life or not I
choose
no went out with her a second time
honestly I did smashed it it was fun
dude but it was like dude
dude I didn't take her to dinner
again
wow so many problems in the world
huh I keep trying to do [__] meetings
and [__] on Zoom I do meetings on Zoom I
did one yesterday I did one the day
before to do my recovery work and it's
just like man I did 14 in a row in a day
and then I didn't on the 15th day I felt
like [__]
dude I want to do 90 days you're
supposed to do 90 and 90 days I [__]
haven't gotten to 90 yet I keep trying
and that's what we do dude I'll tell you
what man today you know what today is a
wash I woke up at 6 p.m. like I'm in
high school and it was homecoming last
night like dude you
know I have
kids but I had a good show I had good
shows man I sure did [__] ice I sure
did
[__] I think that's it for the
episode you know what you guys I had a
great time uh thanks for chilling with
me uh Merry Christmas I'll see you next
week I think we're going to do a
Christmas episode there's a chance we
may just skip the week but uh may not I
don't know we'll see uh appreciate you
and uh I will be in Albuquerque and El
Paso and Phoenix and Brea go get tickets
at Chris le.com and then also go watch
my special grow or die chris.com
appreciate you that's it for the YouTube
episode if you want to see the rest of
the episode The Raw the uncut the uh
episode where you uh get to see
everything and no ads go to uh
patreon.com/crashcourse
[Music]
problem
[__]